I saw up what was the other theory
dissolved without alpha okay so I still
have no safe over here over here how can
I do this well when you've got just
shrugged it off could you've got
simultaneous equations you get you solve
this update we solved for y rank is we
can selectors what do you do with why
you put a basket to your equations right
now usually with simultaneous equations
solid rock you're ready to put into one
right but there's a bit of problem we
try that sub R into let's just try
equation one and see what happened
let's take you root 3 cos alpha equals
root 3 on 2 yeah so if I divide both
sides think use me that which is fine
it's true it's just not enough for me
right because we've stopped equations
like this - we were blue in the face we
know it is not just one solution to that
is the solution for that right if I had
infinite number of solutions so I need
to restrict this in a some other way you
have to do more than just sub R into
your first equation you actually have to
sub into both of them right I'm going to
do that
okay you can tell me that sooner
bollocks
so if I want just to look at this
equation up here cos alpha equals R half
right you can come with two solutions in
a normal domain for that what will be
your first solution 60 but you know
cosine keep going you're going to get
another solution in the fourth quadrant
right and that solution would be 300
degrees 60 or 300 but the only you know
this other piece of information you can
rule one it's about see the nice visual
way to do it we've talked about
quadrants before right yes when you
wrote down cos alpha equals 1/2 you
instantly knew to the quadrants 4 okay
and to or does need to okay and the
other two causes negative over there so
you can't use those right but then when
you write down to sign up equals this
now you know actually these are the only
two quadrants you can be in right and
you have to solve a asleep satisfy both
of them right so that's why you've got
to be in here that's 300 degrees you
found satisfies this but not this one
right so therefore with both equations I
can say alpha equals sixty degrees okay
now this is the point at which I'm going
to explain why even though it was
actually very very very common sense and
on insightful it actually is not a very
good idea to go from here and cancel out
our first watch what happens let's say 1
all the way around 2/1 okay we've just
established the odds go away I'm going
to get 1 on the left hand side and then
on the right hand side
- this / - this the twos will cancel
right we find Gemma - and then you get
three divided by root three by
definition is root three right and
here's the thing you remember again we
got multiple solutions for like a this
but we were like it's cool
I've got enough information to get rid
of the multiplication and work out which
is the real one which one's the
important okay but when you're over here
the kind of stuff right this guy can
tell this guy's like this or maybe this
they're not not information if you just
divide through right dividing through
disappears some of the data we actually
need it to success with what he'll not
be able force so that's why I don't do
it I you can see conveniently it might
be this piping are in situations I'll
show you that later it could just as
well be that and you have to know based
on the situation okay a tale you in
found are empty you found alpha that's
the auxilary angle so now I can say this
thing up here and not just equal to this
summer to function it also equal to this
put all together root three sine of X
plus each other
thumb so after the question will simply
be state this it turns off and then
they'll provide for you another form
like our sine X plus alpha Norfolk box
ago